[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
can you hear me yes sir can you hear me
I can I can hear you in a Hessa
talk yes sir what's going on with you
didn't even say I'm lost my Xbox headset
oh [__]
I'm trying to figure out where I put it
I'm sorry Chad just give me one second
it's been a long day oh we're live I was
about to eat these damn Doritos
let me close up the bag
I thought we were one second let me find
this stupid headset
keep talking so I can hear you through
that yes what is up everybody
[Music]
what's up what's up
thanks for stopping by
all right Mike what's up Donna Taco
what's up man
ah okay okay I found it
I know you like that yo Donna Taco I I
know you like high five rust since you
love Splatoon so much
okay okay can you can you see my camera
in there
I can see it on the stream but I can't
see it here but so yeah we can see I
don't know like this happened last time
I could see you on on the YouTube stream
but I can't see you like
on stream Labs or whatever but you know
so it's good it's not about what it like
when I see you enough it's about to chat
it's interesting like it it should show
you but show me but it's not I don't
know
I'm showing you like a
I don't know
who knows all right so we're gonna just
get it on with it who cares
let's go
what's going on you guys
gaming added here I went straight from
the live stream straight to a video
straight to this podcast
it's been rough man it's been rough but
man you know this we got a lot to talk
about it's been an eventful week man an
eventful week
so uh dirt what you've been playing man
uh
actually
um I just finished Spider-Man Miles
Morales I you know I I never got a
chance to finish it before
I was actually it was actually pretty
good it's it's a Spider-Man game
obviously but it was actually pretty
good
um something else I was playing I can't
think of it right now yeah I don't know
but yeah I just finished Spider-Man
Miles Morales
um but I will be I will be downloading
Hi-Fi rush though yeah that actually
really that really
that really threw me off guard that yeah
but we'll get to it we'll get to it man
we got a lot to talk about today yes sir
you want any technical
we got an absurd amount to talk about
today
you know uh some Xbox some PlayStation
some not uh you know it's it's been a
good day man it's been a good day I
actually can't wait to talk about this
direct because uh it's kind of my raw
feelings about it so far uh it's had a
couple minutes to seek in but I wouldn't
say that I I know anything yet so uh you
know it's uh you know let's let's get
started show Welcome to the attic show
we talk about the past present future
game I got my coach with me dirt
grickety what's going on dirt what's up
everybody hope you guys enjoyed that
Xbox developer direct it was good it was
good I did so I enjoyed it yeah so uh
you know we we got a little bit of
topics today we will get to the
developer direct uh you know I like to
call it the Xbox direct uh you know they
I wonder if XBox if they wanted to name
it Xbox Direct in one one way shape or
form uh because I I feel like
that name has a good stigma to it you
know what I'm saying but they went with
developer direct I actually think it was
a very solid show we'll get into that a
little bit more in the future we're
going to talk about Perfect Dark Rumors
apparently uh there's some form of
rumors going around about that uh you
know we'll talk about whether or not to
believe those we're gonna talk about The
Last of Us TV show success
you know we didn't really Branch too
much into it last week we're going to
talk about it this week we're gonna talk
about it this week for spoken
hahaha
yeah I'm sorry I shouldn't have done I'm
sorry and we talking about the developer
direct so first thing let's let's get
straight off to uh you know what we
playing what you've been playing there
like I said I uh feel this Spider-Man
Miles Morales um
what else I've been playing something
but why I can't like gotta jump on there
fortnite oh King oh that's right I'm
still
playing Gotham nights yeah that one but
uh I pre-played I pre-ordered Dead Space
so in a couple days I will put my 100
focus on Dead Space
that fortnite was me and King okay me
and King been playing that a little too
much here like a little too much
I I you know I've been playing fortnite
um I am playing um
uh Fire Emblem engaged I am playing that
so that's been an interesting uh time
it's it's been a good time for gaming
man you know we got a lot coming up
we've got a lot to play already you know
I would say that game pass has been uh
hitting it too you know with the rise
with the the Monster uh Hunter arise we
got the Persona three and four coming to
the platform and Dane Dayton Game Pass
has been a pretty good thing man but you
know speaking of Xbox you know let's
talk about this perfect Dart if you
heard about these rumors that apparently
it's it's gotten behind in development
and Tomb Raider it's probably gonna
launch before
yeah I saw that um
I I don't I don't believe it unless I'm
hearing it from like a guy like Jason
schreier or Jeb grub or somebody I don't
you know nah
this is me I mean if it's true that's
you know unfortunate but
we saw the Fable rumors a week ago or
two weeks ago that was a lie you know we
seeing all these rumors and sometimes
people just make up stuff but like I
said unless I hear from Jason schreier
or Jazz Corden what's up bro I'm not I'm
not going to buy into it
you know that's just me though what do
you think do you think that it's
possible that
because it's been so easy to Target
Microsoft here lately that people are
choosing like people are looking for or
just making stuff up in general
absolutely uh because you know there's
obviously been some issues with some
first party studios in the past whether
it's 343 you know we heard that every
wild has some issues
um you know
with perfect dark actually you know
adding adding Crystal Dynamics so people
kind of made that a negative so yeah
because there's some history with some
issues maybe not big issues but there's
some issues yeah people are running with
that so they're easy to pick on
if there's been previous issues so I
think that's exactly what it is
exactly what I think it is
yeah I think uh it's sad in a way you
know hopefully Perfect Dark doesn't have
no issues but I do think it might be a
little bit more of this Witch Hunt just
trying to make bad Xbox news because
it's been so accessible and so easy to
do yeah I agree I agree uh you know
there ain't really a whole lot to talk
about that but I knew that you know some
people probably going to want us to talk
about to some degree
um you know I understand where there's
fire uh where the smoke there's fire but
I I need to know if there's even smoke
like you know even when you look at
something like
they um
in the initiative having issues
and then burning other people on the
platform
there's a lot of different aspects that
that could have happened and I get it
that it's probably easy because
Microsoft does have some mismanaging
going on on their individual Studios but
I'm not there to say that the whole
stable is having issues I think you know
when you when you got 20 plus kids man
somebody gonna act up absolutely
somebody will rob people some of them
gonna steal stuff like you're gonna have
to probably visit the police station a
couple times but it's it's just what
that's what raising kids is and that's
what they're initially doing you know
they raising kids man I knew a family
like that at it it was 12 of them
two of them was thugs bro with the rest
of them they were pretty pretty a lot of
body sentences but you know what I like
though I like the thugs don't try to
corrupt the non thugs like they're like
look we get it we we went down the dark
side we get it man they was in the
streets bro but yeah but but you're
right though you're absolutely right
that's like um like you said if a person
has a history of criminal activity
when something happens
when they're around they're looking at
them like did you still did you steal my
sandwich you piece of trash like no I
didn't but your history makes you think
that you know that's the first person
they look at so that's just Dr Phil
coming out of nowhere saying the the
lighter to determined that that was a
lie right
so if your history you know you had some
similar things happen before it's easy
to say oh it's happening again
but you got to prove it man you gotta
know you guys can't be making up stuff
bro do you think that this shows how
important it is for Microsoft to turn
these studios around so they can get rid
of that bad stigma I highly absolutely
100 I said not too long ago the only
people that can shut up these
PlayStation Fanboys isn't us isn't us
Bots
those XBox guys we can't shut up the
PlayStation fan boys Xbox is the only
people that can shut them up
yeah they're still gonna have issues
with the pro uh you know don't give them
don't give them ammunition don't don't
give them a rocket and say Don't Shoot
Me
like
don't give them any extra ammo and
sometimes I feel like Microsoft be bad
on giving them ammo man yeah but I think
it's you know leveling out I think will
for the most part see stuff to start to
calm down a little bit I get it you know
we're gonna move right on with this man
we we're gonna talk about The Last of Us
TV show success now we we about 16
minutes and 10 seconds you know for the
time stamp uh Mafia you know I don't
want you guys you don't want no issues
at it yeah so you know Last of Us man
how many episodes have you watched have
you watched this both of them both of
them okay love it love it yeah we don't
want to go too much into the detail of
the episodes so you know but what I do
want to know from you is what is your
overall
opinion on the show as a whole without
spoiling anything
um I absolutely love it you know I've
always been consistent even though I'm a
bot I told people from the beginning I
love the lives The Last of Us franchise
a little guy or franchise I said that
from the beginning and um it is one of
my favorite PlayStation franchises
one of my favorite fans are at Superior
um I think it's fire bro I have to admit
um it does make you want to go back and
play the game
I have PlayStation Plus premium so I
played The Last of Us and re-bleached uh
you know I had a trial I had a two hour
you know like the two hour trial I went
back played um this this the show was
pretty solid man the last episode was
pretty good and um Neil Drucker did a
pretty good job directing that show so
yeah I'm I'm loving this show even
though you know it's kind of some things
that's gonna happen if you played the
game but
it's a it's a good show I'm not going to
cap Mama be as honest as I can be it's a
good show man
yeah do you um
do you think that last of the shows to
these
these these issues when it comes to
Hollywood and people making TV shows
that like look you can make gaming
content in the TV form in a movie form
and you can make it
Source material and stay true to the
source and still be mild uh and still be
wild successful
yeah you can do that but I think the
thing is this is HBO's most expensive
show they've ever made
not every company is going to be willing
to do that
um you can definitely make the source
material like as accurate as as it can
be but how many
you know people are going to want to do
that like with the gears awards show
that's supposed to come up in the future
I believe it's Netflix right Netflix
possibly are they going to buy like how
close are they going to be to the source
material I hope it's close as The Last
of Us is
um but you know it depends on how far
they're willing to go obviously HBO felt
yo we're going to go all the way they
they spent some money on that show and
it shows it's a good show man like the
feel of the show is just like the damn
game no doubt about it
um so I hope most more studios are more
streaming services or whatever they put
that money behind these shows and I hope
it shows you know I hope the Gears Award
Show was like that
well I don't care about Eloy but I hope
that's so easy for like that too but
yeah
and you know I like that you brought up
the only thing it's kind of crazy that
how much Sony's getting into the TV
stuff right now oh yeah it's like every
show I feel like is making a TV show to
some degree every every game they've
made is making some form of TV show yeah
I'm waiting for that nap game no I'm
joking
um yeah bro like Disney gonna make that
yeah it does seem that way and and I
love it because we're Gamers right so we
we
love that our favorite hobby things that
we love like me bro I live video games
I've been like this from a little kid
video games is always my favorite thing
to do you know video games and
eventually sports but now that I'm older
it's even more video games now
I love to see that video games and
finally getting the credit that they
deserve you know there were some movies
in the past with the exception of the
first Mortal Kombat most video game
movies were trash so to see they
actually putting money into and uh these
games movie games I should say I love it
bro I love it oh am I low let me see it
I can turn this both up
I'm ready for that
all right he should sound better now no
okay I turned you up on my end
am I better flame do I sound a little
bit higher he wants to hear that voice
hold on isn't this hairy guy a pony he
said so is amazing see I don't know if
he's being real or he's being sarcastic
the Xbox show is amazing you're like you
you you're questioning his motives right
now because I don't trust no pony man I
don't I don't trust him man they could
be oh the show was amazing but they're
being sarcastic three bit what's up
brother
just love you sister
I feel like when it comes to what's
going on right now I just
I guess so annoyed like I I really do
like I get so annoyed when it comes to
these TV shows and these movies
that these people do not care about what
the gamer output is they're like you
know we're gonna take Resident Evil and
we're gonna change so much stuff that
it's not gonna make sense to anyone if
they didn't respect it right they
respect the story they say oh we put our
own story and what you wouldn't it be
fair okay you know correct me if I'm
wrong Dirk but wouldn't it be fair to
assume that if you make a video game
movie a huge other audience that you're
trying to Target is Gamers absolutely
but you don't they're like you know what
we kind of want to reach Gamers but I I
think
one of the biggest issues we have in the
industry is people
that wants to get as much as the Casual
audience as possible I think that's the
biggest issue because when you try to
constantly get the Casual audience
you're always going to overlook the the
people who actually put you where you
are I think that's what's wrong with the
gaming industry I think I if I were at a
betting mat I would say the the issue
with the gaming issue right now is is a
combination of a couple things one cloud
these these developers and Publishers
mainly Publishers they're jealous of
other companies why can't I have Rock
Steady money why why can't I have
Destiny money why
and then they try to make these
half-assed products that doesn't do a
fraction of the stuff that these other
games that they're they're envying
towards and lusting towards and then
when they don't get the same results or
they get laughed out of the building
they're like well I guess I just don't
belong in the know you you belong in the
industry but you can't like here's the
thing
when it comes to games as a service and
you know chat feel free to put in the
chat uh we got a two dollar Super Chat
from 108 Dragon TV dirt Pony Master
looking for you sucker hey I don't want
no smoke I think she wants you to read
it he think he wants you to read that
dirt Pony Master looking for you sucker
so I don't want to smoke smoke with the
pony Master what would you would would
you think it was a fair thing to say
that a games as a service is only
realistically
going to take you so far because after
you have enough of them in the in the
field I can honestly say there's only
enough time in Gamer's life for one
maybe two maybe two yeah most the time
it's it's one let's be real here people
playing Destiny they've been it took me
I was on that train with I couldn't find
an exit for years
I ran around that Destiny train looking
for an exit and there was nowhere to be
found I had to jump off the train I got
hurt
jumping off that train
I ain't trying to go back on that train
I'm you know what's funny is I see
something like this
this Elder Scrolls online and I'm like I
might jump on that train
because I have I have freed myself from
the destiny clutches now obviously you
know I've already scheduled for my uh my
yearly pickup on Destiny when the
expansion comes out at the end of the
year
so you know we we we good we we doing
this man we doing this
what's up I think that's
when it comes to uh the the TV stuff I
just want them to respect it that's all
and I feel like the ones that do respect
it don't get enough credit like I've
said multiple times I will support
Sonic
as long as that sucker's out because
when the develop when the the producers
and the team behind making the Sonic
movies
showed that Abomination Sonic and and
The Gamers spoke out they said we ain't
about this take that thing off of it
because it's not Sonic they went back to
that room and they spent millions of
dollars
30 million dollars reanimating Sonic and
it was a w and to me to me that needs to
be rewarded to me us as Gamers can't sit
there and demand something but when
people say yo you right let me fix it we
don't show up right like to me when
someone does something good for the
gaming industry we need to show up in
waves like like an army man we we need
to show up that you make stuff we will
be there but if you don't respect us
none of us coming
facts I agree with that and Sonic 2 I
think it's in the top five video game
movies I think it's the number one oh is
it that's that's fire man I love it
because you're right about that because
when they first showed that Sonic were
like okay who the hell is that that
ain't the solid we know and love uh but
them going back to the drawing board
spending 30 million dollars to fix Sonic
excuse me now and it paid off for them
and and because of that they they're on
their third movie yeah they listen to US
20 bucks say they didn't fix Sonic they
wouldn't have made a second one no
probably not because I know I
wasn't gonna go watch it I know I'm not
gonna go watch it but when they showed
that I said there and I there's probably
iops you could find this where I was
like
I'ma respect that I'm gonna go watch
that movie yeah and when the second one
came out guess what they got enough
credit from me from going back there and
fixing that I'm like I'm gonna give you
guys a second one and a third one and a
fourth one like until the movies are bad
you're gonna see attic there at the
movies day one every week yeah yeah
because I enjoyed part two at least
listen as a gamer bro we're all Gamers I
just love how video games is getting
loved in Hollywood like real love
not the you know Mario Brothers from uh
what was the like the 90s with the
terrible Mario Brothers real like they
doing the animated Mario I'm not a
Nintendo fan but that Mario brother
movie I'm watching that I'm watching
yeah it looks dope man I don't even like
a lot of people don't like the animated
stuff
um I get it you want a live action but
to me do what's gonna justify the film
what's gonna make it good and to me when
I see that Mario thing sure you maybe
people feel like it's directed more
towards kids I guess
I'ma be there I'ma be there with my
non-pop corn because I eat popcorn but
we gonna imagine me with some popcorn
and I'ma watch that stuff obviously now
I gotta watch it because r r with the
Lord's being King shout out to that you
know go over there and uh support us on
that but I'm gonna watch that I'm gonna
watch that
um you know I'm a huge movie person and
to me as long as you respect what's
going on I'mma Be There 100 every time
yep yeah that's like that's us man
that's you know like we love the games
and for them to give the movies I mean
to give the video games the respect that
they deserve I love it and I agree with
you wholeheartedly
yeah so I mean ain't really a whole lot
to talk about that I do want to bring
out something real quick before we move
on when they talk about The Last of Us
show I saw
a couple people on Twitter saying that
they understand the last of a show but
they're kind of disappointed that they
have to watch a recreation of the game
like they didn't interview too much and
I'm like shut up
okay please everybody we we've literally
been asking for this for decades
all those people elong get them out get
them out of there Twitter deactivate we
ain't trying to hear none of that stuff
like look
am I gonna know what happens every week
yes am I still gonna be there watching
of course right the clickers looked like
it was amazing like those clickers they
scared me yeah and not to mention I'm a
big I'm a big fan of these stories
that's in these games have never been
respected by Hollywood ever they've
always considered them a video game not
a story now when you have stuff like
Last of Us coming out
destroying actual movies and TV shows
and ratings
it shows these games have contents these
games have stories these games are
beginning middle and end and I love it I
love it
you know I agree with you man hey let me
tell you something those clickers of
course we're not gonna spoil too much
because I mean everybody knew there's
gonna be clickers in the show
um
watching the show
I remember how I felt the first time
playing the game when those clickers
showed up
bro the stealth kind of somehow
recreated how I was feeling when I was
playing the game when left with like
when the clickers first showed up it was
like yo what the hell are those
and he was kind of like oh man so yeah
they did a great job bro
yeah and you know I'm gonna be there
every week I see I've played last of us
now I do think that maybe Sony shouldn't
have tried to capitalize so much on the
Last of Us Part One because they were
trying to get that game out before the
show it looked like but to me I feel
like I feel like all you really did is
people that skipped on playing it in
2013 which even if you played it in 2013
I feel like if that game didn't come out
the story would hit a little bit better
with us because we ain't played in like
five years yeah yeah but some people
literally just got off playing the
replay literally just got off playing
the Remake but I know you saw how sales
went up 300 or something like that yeah
good good so you know trying to make any
sense now that you look back yeah you
know like The Last of Us re-bleached
kind of made sense
um for people that saw the show and
didn't and never played the game so it
did make a little sense
yeah but you know Sony they
strategically put that game in place
then I understand I I do think that you
know for your fans maybe you should have
released it after the show
because I do feel like you're having a
lot of people that literally just played
the Remake like literally just played it
and you're having aspects where people
are like look I I know this story well
yeah you played it two weeks ago like so
I I think maybe you should have held
those cards a little bit longer just
just a little bit I got you all right so
you know what's coming
what what's what's on your mind
for spoken 31 minutes and 40 seconds we
talking about for spoken
all right man did you play for spoken no
I had no idea I had to download the demo
I have oh yeah okay
yes
one thing I will say is
the the
um
the dialogue The cringy Thing
the the dialogue the cringe thing I do
think is being exaggerated
um I get it she's from New York so New
Yorkers expect her to sound a certain
way I get it that's valid criticism that
is
but
I think you're expecting her to sound
like the New Yorker that you would
expect to hear not
there's probably people in New York that
speak like that let's be real here like
maybe not many but there's most likely
people that sound like her in New York
is it crazy yes
she sounds very immature uh she she
doesn't sound like but you got to keep
in mind from the perspective of of
someone going into a fantasy world their
mind's blowing I think maybe they should
have a little bit better uh dialogue
with it but I get why people are upset I
think the biggest issue isn't even hurt
I think it's the gauntlet the little
thing that talks to her on her on her on
her arm the thing is so cringe-worthy
because it will be a lot yeah it would
be a lot better
it with her cringe if he didn't have
cringe you know what I'm saying like she
speaks in and like he's a serious tone
kind of person but he pretty much
co-signs everything she does okay oh
she's like oh you know I'm Gonna Learn
these pennies like we're gonna learn
these abilities I'm like why are you
even talking like that like and first
off I don't like this part where they
cut Venom
I mean um
I don't like the second no I'm saying
it's the it's the wristband like Venom
say we are going to do this we do this
and stuff like that
like you know what I'm saying right you
know how like yeah yeah
I feel you I feel you on that that's uh
you know I think Venom's a little bit
different because he was an established
character oh God uh so you know people I
don't know if victims like that in the
in the comic books but one thing I will
say is I think the issue
isn't even the cringe I think the the
controllers are clunky in a lot of ways
I think that's
the story don't really make a whole lot
of sense like one second she wants to go
home one second she doesn't I'm only
like five hours in and I I I don't know
if I could go back to it but it's just
like because I'm playing and it's not
anything about the game I'm playing
um I'm playing Fire Emblem and I'm gonna
play this this new game that just came
out on Xbox like like forespoken
probably ain't being played by me right
I'll be real with you I'm gonna be real
with you uh shout out to Square Enix for
sending me the review code though no uh
you know yeah yeah I just
this ain't it you know I I understand
people wanted to go out uh the
individual uh that played the
protagonist
I unders I get it you know especially
New Yorkers you're like you know she
needs to sound a certain way and I get
it you guys have every right to think
that but I don't when I listen to I just
roll my eyes I don't get angry over it
you know what I'm saying it's just like
because I don't I don't live in a run
where I think everyone
in Virginia and West Virginia speak
exactly the same of course not uh and
it's just it blows my mind that people
have that kind of mentality you know
what I'm saying like yeah and I get it
New Yorkers and like Boston people
they're very different
yeah they're like they gotta sound
exactly how I expect her to sound like
so I get it I get I'm not gonna say and
I'm not gonna say she's not
cringe-worthy she's definitely
cringe-worthy it's just I feel like the
issue is mainly with the bracelet
because she should have a different type
he should have a different tone that
kind of balances her character out
gotcha
um yeah I haven't played it I um from
what I'm seeing from outside looking in
because I haven't played it it seems
like that engine that luminous is using
is trash
um for a PS5 game to drop to 720P
that engine I will agree someone said
the uh the cussing is ridiculous yeah
she does cost a little bit too much for
like no reason oh okay okay I don't know
um yeah so listen I like the game
initially I thought the game looked fine
but the more they showed of the game the
more I said nah it's not really my thing
yeah but I do think that um I mean I'm
not gonna call it a studio trash but
whatever engine they're using seems to
be trash
and people's like uh this studio
probably closed down now they'll
probably go back to making Final Fantasy
they made Final Fantasy XV you know but
they need to change engines bro I
actually feel like what would have been
a better story I'm tired of people going
from The Real World to a fantasy world
let's have someone op come from a
fantasy world to the real world not even
op imagine her living in that other
world she's got ability she's got magic
but she's like the weakest person there
you know what I'm saying and then she
comes over in the real world and she's
like a god to them because she has
powers
hey interesting yeah so it is what it is
uh I think Final Fantasy you know they
they gonna snatch those developers back
up I I would be very surprised that for
spoken got a sequel like extremely yeah
I don't think I mean I ain't hating on
the game I don't think it's gonna do
well hey Jerry Bishop I was thinking
that exact same thing he said my dude
called for Last Action Hero game because
when you said that like a fantasy world
to the real world that's the first thing
I thought about was Last Action Hero I
don't know if you ever saw that before
no I haven't I love the movie but people
bastard but yeah that's the first thing
I thought of Jared Bishop it's funny you
said that
oh man yeah so you know it is what it is
uh I hate that the game came out the way
it is but at the same time you know I
feel like sometimes these these
Publishers and developers because these
games are made years at a time they get
out of touch of what's actually going on
and if you're out of touch for uh and
you're not in the times at that time
you're probably already a year or six
months out of what's hot and then you
add on the three to four year lifespan
it takes to make a game on top of being
out of touch so you can be potentially
out of touch for like four years when
you make a game uh developing a game is
not easy and that's why I get so annoyed
when I feel like
I feel like people need to
stick with what they do good I don't
like when developers try to go way off
the broaden path to do something
different that didn't work out for them
because then they put their studio in a
situation where they might get closed
down and I don't want none of these
students to get closed I want every
Studio to stay around as long as
possible because we get as many type of
games as possible
I agree
I love games and I don't want no Studio
to get closed down so yep I agree with
you yeah so I mean we that's pretty much
all when it comes to that man there
wasn't a whole lot we could talk about
for smoking you know it is what it is
like and hopefully you know when they
make this next game they'll realize like
look like you know this this didn't work
now we need to do something different we
need to make sure that the the controls
felt really clunky so like sometimes I
feel like I'm trying to make her do
something she does something completely
different
um you know maybe once you unlock some
abilities that gets a little bit better
but I like to feel slow
until I've built up abilities to go fast
and go fast to control those abilities
you know what I'm saying right because
she's fast like when she learns those
abilities man she she kicking it she
going straight in man she going straight
in right
all right let's let's talk about it dirt
the main event of the evening the main
event we're gonna we're gonna say 30
minutes and 45 seconds long oh not 39
yeah okay I I messed up there it's fine
it's fine it's fine now I'm gonna say 50
minutes time stop Mafia going man you
got to get it right man
what they gonna do to me they just gonna
complain in the comments section I'm
doing them a service okay it is what it
is you guys better think dirt because
dirt suggested doing it Live you
wouldn't get no no time I'm gonna be
real with you you would not get time
stamps that's the way they do it brother
developer direct man I'm gonna call it
Xbox Direct that's what it's called to
me yeah what's your overall thoughts man
first off let's let's let's let's rake
it back a little bit I want to peel too
many layers off I want to peel that fine
thin layer in the front man that frying
thin air on the front tell me your your
rating uh no let's say that for last
how'd you like the format how did you
like the format dirt yeah
I love the format now initially I was
thinking it was going to be more like a
stated play or a Nintendo Direct no
they're doing their own little thing uh
no it's kind of a mixture I I would say
the best way to describe it is a
Nintendo Direct but it's going in
instead of having 15 games they're doing
like four to five and they're they're
opening up dialogue and explaining
certain situations with the game yep and
I actually like
um the developers kind of talking over
the gameplay
I appreciate that because I do like
sometimes when the developers talk about
their game I want to hear certain things
about the game so I love the format um
like you know how like stay to play
or Nintendo director like there's a
voice like a robotic voice or a woman
yeah so this next game so so they
obviously didn't do that but I love the
way they did it
um and I'm looking forward to seeing
more of these in the future because like
we know Xbox has a lot of content and
development and yeah I did like the
format I I really did and it had five
games one was a surprise and they told
us ahead of time what the games would be
so that's what's funny to me that show
was trash they told you guys the games
that was going to be there
I had a dog I had a
um a picture that showed everything that
was at this event and I'm still
disappointed that wasn't their look I
get it maybe you guys wanted a you know
a surprise I feel like the you know the
game the uh what's that game called
half eyebrows high five uh how far is I
think that's a good surprise especially
yeah because we got day and date you
know just just think about that dirt
Microsoft announced and released a game
within 15 minutes that was dope that was
dope and it was a nice looking game it
does look like it's a 30 game on Steam
so yeah they say it's I think it costs
40 they said listen this is what I was
thinking when we heard rumors about
Tango Gameworks who I love I love The
Evil Within franchise I haven't played
ghost by Tokyo yet but obviously I will
soon when it comes to Xbox
um when we you know like we hear passion
projects that we kind of say okay that's
cool
but what is it going to be you know
we've seen the passion process in the
past
so when they showed this game off I was
like okay
okay that that looks pretty good hold on
let me hold on for a second
Chris hard stop it so I'm a no star
field right they told you sorry for it
wasn't going to be there stop request
but I did hope that we would see like a
teaser that's shown when the net when
the event is or something like that I'm
glad that they came out at the beginning
of the month said you ain't getting that
like you know how bad this would be if
we didn't know that and we went into
this event expecting Starfield and we
watched the whole thing it was like
where's Starfield
yeah yeah that bruh them telling us
ahead of time
what like kind of soften the blow but
like just imagine if you know like your
girls tell you yo you're not getting
anything tonight
don't ask me
okay
you know ahead of time when you get into
bed go to sleep because you ain't
getting nothing
right so Xbox tell us uh a few weeks
ahead of time stockfield would not be
there so we know not to expect Starfield
I appreciate the transparency
my mindset is they're like well it needs
its own Big Show yeah okay yeah
um Elder Scrolls was here and it had its
own Big Show it happened probably right
now still yeah Forza has apparently had
one tomorrow and it was at this event
yeah so that's why I'm like if these are
the ones can do it
why can't this one do it got a two
dollar from Jess probably butchered your
name man my bad we're gonna move on
finally uh Xbox finally released a game
can't wait to play it does look good uh
I'm gonna play uh Fire Emblem I'm still
playing that but then I'm gonna head on
over there scoots on over there and try
that game out yeah I agree so let's get
into these games I think that's
important uh kinda
so Minecraft Legends they opened up with
Minecraft did that surprise you in any
way shape or form well I think you know
it it looks fun it's not really my
Boogie I'm not a Minecraft guy but this
one looks interesting though I'm not I'm
still not quite sure exactly what it is
or or like what is it similar to like
what do you think
to be honest with you I was trying my
hardest to listen because King was
cracking jokes like the whole time okay
so so it was the same with me even
though I heard like every other word it
seemed like uh but
it it seemed like a MOBA
yeah but because I saw like lines of of
of uh you know ads and stuff but at the
same time it seemed like maybe it's a
survival game like an arc that's more
centered around like PVP between two
individual groups or three or four
depending on how many people's on the
map uh it's interesting it seemed like
these are long-term matches I don't know
I feel like they showed us a lot yeah
huh
like it is a PVP yeah it seemed like
they gave us a lot of information but
didn't really give us a lot of
information
hello
oh I think dirt dropped out
show on show there can you hear me yeah
I can hear you hey can you guys still
still hear me yeah
I have no clue it was like you got you
out of here uh back to what I was saying
I think my they showed a lot about
Minecraft I'm probably gonna watch the
4K trailer after this but they showed a
lot about it and I feel like I saw all
that gameplay and I still have no clue
what this game's about yeah but it looks
fine though yeah I mean it looks fun I
think that
that looks like something fun and if
they do that kind of game right
especially on PC they could be just as
big as Minecraft you know especially
rolling off the Minecraft name right
yeah you know if it's a survival game
that you can like build these towns and
stuff like I think I think it could hit
it could hit hard man it can hit hard
huh Donna Taco said the PVP is like a
RTS mixed with some Tower Defense and
mobile like elements okay
that's cool and I think thanks uh when I
was reading that it makes sense I just
gotta see it I gotta see it yeah that's
cool see that's the thing like but every
game might not be for us but there's
plenty other people in the world that
will enjoy this game so that's what I
love about the diversity of Xbox I was
telling Paul I was like you guys because
we have a a decent relationship with
Microsoft I was like we need to hit up
our peoples and be like yo we would love
to have us versus the devs well sure
we're going to get stomped by no means
we're gonna win that but I think it will
show that you know this game the
potential of this game because we we did
it with a couple games you know and I
feel like
we're probably going to do of demio
because they're making a PVP mode but I
think it'll be fun man I think it'll be
fun I don't know if something like that
will happen
normally they're pretty they're pretty
strict on you know because there's so
much stuff going on I don't know if
they'll let a couple devs come off that
project to uh come on the show and uh
streamless since the addict uh do I have
a question why redfall look like a 360
game it isn't that funny coming from
Chris Hart who was hyping the hell out
of uh forespoken
Chris Hart I'm gonna need something I'm
gonna need you to come to the to the
front of the room and explain what
happened
to forespoken yeah I would love for him
to explain that go ahead Chris on an
hour I'm listening
explain that
he went away
we're waiting the chat and us are at
your disposal we're giving you the
platform 265 people are watching Chris
explain to us
why we should play for spoken yeah you
know that's a great hey that's a great
question Daddy go ahead
Chris it's Ryan that's why spoken is
amazing and better than every Xbox game
go ahead
enough for spoken combat is very dynamic
dynamic
that's productive all righty he doesn't
even have the game all he does
disappeared oh man
we are wait yeah come on Chris it was
happening don't know Chris don't do that
he was hyping that game after the demo
that ain't scam you but if you like it
you like it man that's fine you know you
can like it
days gone and that game got bass but I
actually like that game it's okay it's
okay Chris you know we sometimes you
don't hit man sometimes you don't hit
you know I would have preferred
Starfield to be at this event I really
wanted to see it uh the good thing is I
don't think I'll have to wait long you
know I I think probably within the month
and a half to two we will see just what
we saw imagine because they said they
want to dedicate in a whole event to
Starfield they got a lot to show yeah uh
so it's going to be interesting if that
does come out so let's let's move on uh
let's move on to
Elder Scrolls I Won't Say I'm not the
biggest fan of the Elder Scrolls Online
I I generally uh go towards like Skyrim
and stuff you know what's funny is
people in the chat was saying they need
to make a Skyrim too Skyrim is a
continent on Tamriel
is that that's how they make their games
Elder Scrolls Skyrim is Elder Scrolls
five
Elder Scrolls 4
is cereal and that was Oblivion
and then before that was more one uh I
think I think Oblivion was the only one
they didn't name it after the actual
continent and that's because the reason
they did that is because it was during
the Oblivion crisis and that's why they
named it Oblivion
so when you looked at it did you even
want to try this game I mean all the
DLCs are free
uh you know what I have never played an
Elder Scrolls game and especially Elder
Scrolls online so I really didn't really
know what I was looking at it looked
fine I guess
um but I would love to hear an opinion
from a fan of Elder Scrolls online
because I can't really speak on it I
never played it before
but it's cool that they have a lot more
content dropping and they actually gave
a date for this content um I forgot what
the day was so the date itself will
force us so I think that's pretty yeah
we're gonna get to that yeah all right
gonna get to that so you know um I do
think that the fact that they're giving
all those expansions is pretty good are
those expansions in Game Pass or do you
have to buy those expansions oh I don't
know that's a good question someone in
the chat tell me tell me how are you
doing what's up
dummy chat I need to know is those
in-game passive you got to buy them
so let's move let's move into the to the
to the first little stat like stabby
stat you know that that knife that's on
um
high on life felt like that thing
stabbed me you know Forza Forza
Motorsport
look good for eraser I don't care but
I'm sure a lot of you did then got a
release date how do you feel about that
dirt what's going on that was the only
um thing that you know I was I wasn't
crazy about you know but you know they
do have a show tomorrow there's hope
that they can announce it tomorrow let's
be real what are the odds of them lots
of random live streams are too high but
I would have liked to see a uh date but
still said 2023 so hopefully they drop
it between before June
um so hopefully we'll find out pretty
soon when the day will be but that's
that that's pretty much the only thing
about the show I didn't like I wish they
would have had a release date for Force
but the game itself
yeah looks pretty damn good I'm more of
a Forza Horizon guy
but damn this one looks good all that
stuff they were talking to Ray Trace
reflection during the race and because
you know because I remember that was a
question people said it's only Ray Trace
Reflections on the uh the like the
cutscenes or the replays they said no
during the race
so yeah it looks great man
enforce it looks like forsa yeah it
looks like forsa I think which is great
right Jay let me let me ask you a
question the fact they didn't come out
with a release date at this what do you
think the odds of it hitting that six
months or
um
um I think it will still hit it
I just think they couldn't really
get a date yet like a a a permanent date
you know how like redfall is May 2nd
I just think they don't they didn't want
to commit
you know yet for whatever reason I could
just be you know damage controlling but
um you know I really don't know why they
didn't have a date
like you said the the odds of Tomorrow
them announcing the day is really low
but maybe they will announce a date
tomorrow who knows
yeah I I doubt it I think you're looking
at a September release date for some
reason really I don't know why I think
that it's definitely going to pass that
June I don't know how much it's going to
pass in that June but the fact that we
didn't see that game there and we didn't
see Starfield makes me think that both
of these games are going past that 12
months and they knew they could not not
show both
so they're like look we're going to show
we're going to show this game called uh
called Forza and we're gonna just
we're gonna we're gonna push you back
when it comes to Starfield because if
both of them wasn't there I think we'd
be having a different conversation you
know what I'm saying uh so it is what it
is on that I I really hope that it makes
that that six months I don't know if
it's going to or not well only time will
tell maybe we'll get lucky and tomorrow
they will say maybe they're holding that
release date for their actual fans and
I'd respect them if they did that but
for some reason I feel like that's not
the case that's not the case yeah I mean
if both if Starfield and Forza goes to
the second half I mean you know that
mean that they didn't stay through the
12 month thing but you know how the game
industry yeah stuff happens all the time
um so yeah
maybe if they if the games did slip past
the 12 month thing
maybe they will be hesitant to do that
again at the future E3
um I wouldn't be mad about it just as
long as the games hit this year
so yeah um oh yeah hopefully I they do
announce the date tomorrow that will be
dope
all right so I'm not gonna hold my
breath
Have Fun Spot this is maybe June maybe I
don't know uh apparently there was leaks
or something like that they were going
to do another one of these before E3
um someone said that in my chat I don't
know if that's true no someone did say
that in my chat so let's I kind of agree
with what Harry said right quick let me
say this right uh like real fast at it I
really don't want E3 wasted on force and
start feeling again I agree with this
year's E3 I want to be about you know
future games
not necessarily games that's dropping
this year because if they're going to
have a
a Xbox direct developers direct
dedicated to Starfield we shouldn't see
the game at E3 again and also for some
Motorsport we should see the E3 again
hopefully it drops before E3 ACL aco7
I saved you from being stiped don't make
me regret that okay because you keep
that capitalization thing in my chat
I'll send you back to the shadowbrown
you know maybe maybe I was wrong to not
let flame flame your ass
yeah okay keep it up man keep it up
because I have no problem since you do
the shot over him yeah I sent my friends
there all the time back in the day okay
what makes you think a random dude in
the chat I won't send your ass to the
shot around there you go
all right so
true yeah like redfall date is May 2nd
and that got leaked pretty much I think
it was a couple days off but it got
leaked yeah yeah things we had said at
the force but he was pretty close
all right let's talk about uh
let's have our rifle
who
what'd you think about it what you saw
what you think about it
attic uh we've been doing a show long
enough
for you to know that I love arcane
and redfall looks incredible to me it
looks so good that I'm the first time
I'm going to play solo
then eventually you know I play with
some homies but it looks great to me it
looks great to me um wherefore
bam see like we didn't really know what
to expect you know people would say yo
it's gonna be black uh uh back for blood
or left for dead no
the only thing those games have similar
they're Shooters first person shooters
and Co-op that's it
redfall looked incredible actually after
the show imma go watch it again in 4k
um it just looks great to me man um
some of the you know the characters have
their own original Powers
the town the red fog looks dope I mean I
just can't wait for the game
um I I do like the the horror factor
that it has you know like being in some
of those homes you know with the
flashlight it's dark the vampire run up
on your ass oh okay so I yeah I love it
bro yeah I I think man show some respect
yeah I think that it looks fine you know
I'm still a little bit on the fences
with it you know I'm a huge fan of
Dishonored I really like that flute
maybe I'm just not feeling the vampire
Vibe you know what I'm saying but what I
will say is they showed me that that
that gameplay that I love the choose
your own way of taking on situations
that's still present I like that they
have like that kind of hero thing in
here where you could everyone's got
their own abilities I like that so you
know I do think this game has the
potential to be great it's just I'm
curious if they're gonna pull it off and
I think I think what it is is I get
nervous with when developers that I love
do something different and until I see
it I get nervous gotta shoot all the
super trap for load Metro say Arcane is
smart stay away from May 12th in that in
that Zelda what was that Zelda okay he
always be talking about what's this dude
in the chat said where's Perfect Dark
where's Fable where where it stay in the
K3 stop it stop it bro come on Xbox told
you what games are going to be there
stop it you know what's funny that's all
they can say the event was good the the
show pretty good all right so let's
write this thing okay first off
I want a one to ten from you on the the
show itself like everything actually
let's do the format first just the
format without the content it's like I
want you to rate how this format is from
one to ten just before Man without the
nine no well what made you I'm curious
what made you not say attend
um
I don't know try not to be too much of a
bot
I I think the only thing that would
prevent me from making this attend is I
do think it would be nice to have like
between the games have like a Game Pass
announcement or something you know what
I'm saying like and I'm not saying they
won't do that in the future I think that
this formula is going to evolve
throughout uh the next couple years but
it's it was nice it was very uh very
nice to see this go through and I'm
excited man I'm excited I would have to
give it a 9-2 I think Microsoft if you
ever come across this everyone put in
the chat too man one to ten and uh I
will Shadow about myself you bought
here's
all right flame Burn Them Burn Them
flame use that use that band Hammer
Burns Emilio seven 10 out of 10 else
bro
I just I don't look even though if you
guys didn't like that I don't I don't
see how people didn't like the
presentation I can understand the
content you know
um what would you give the entire event
with no content uh the entire event with
the content I give it a nine I've given
an eight uh because I don't really care
about 88 of the stuff at this event yeah
you know the only ones that
the only ones that really made sense to
me I really enjoyed what I saw on Forza
Motorsport and I really enjoyed what I
saw on redfall to a point you know it
showed me that maybe this game is going
to be something I enjoy but it's besides
that I just didn't see a lot you know
not a lot of it wasn't for me I think
Minecraft looked interesting you know
floors as Forza I don't care about
Racers I think I said Forza earlier
instead of Minecraft but you know I
think that the the indie game that they
launched out I think that looked cool
yeah really cool I just I enjoyed the
format and I feel like
imagine you replacing these games
with
uh with a vowed perfect Dart failed
hellblade
there's so much Elder Scrolls six the
next Doom type of title I don't know
what they're gonna make Quake right
right man whatever compulsions making
right whatever all of us is making like
the Coalition next game yeah if they if
they and then if they buy Activision you
get the next crash type again yeah they
yeah great stuff yeah it was very
important for me for them to fix
the Fiasco known as inside Xbox yeah
yeah look once inside Xbox bad sometimes
it was very cringy it drawn out too much
at most times but I did think that they
could Salvage that that whole show but
it's just like look like
it just seemed like they didn't want to
to relate rely on anyone that doesn't
work for Microsoft for the most part
right he looked like they were like
doing contracts for a certain
personalities and it's just like you
know
when it comes to shows like that you got
to get personalities that are
entertaining and can relate information
in an entertaining way right and I don't
feel like they ever really did that I'm
glad there was no PR people on the show
I'm glad there was no personalities of
that you know Microsoft deems worthy of
putting on these things it's not about
the games yeah I'm glad that the
developers got to tell their games
because at the end of the day you give
them a platform who knows you know maybe
they'll actually put more effort because
they know they're the ones showing these
games I agree brother uh so you know I'm
not saying they're not putting effort
it's just you know we might get better
all quality and features because they
because they're excited when you're
excited you work way harder yep and more
efficient too more efficient but you
know
what you're gonna say oh no I'm about to
say something I was about I totally
agree with what you're saying uh but
something else that you said you just
mentioned all of these other games they
have in development and I think that was
one of the biggest issues with inside
Xbox bro
they didn't have the content like that
back then and they had those shows so
it's fine inside Xbox was usually two
hours of filler or two hours of BS
because they didn't have the content but
like you said moving forward these Xbox
developer directs
are going to be necessary because Xbox
is going to have so much content at the
E3 shows they're going to show the
future stuff the big stuff but remember
before those games drop
they're going to have shows like this
that's going to show deep Dives of a
hellblade 2 before that like a few
months before that drops or a vowed or
outer walls to or any other game you
know that they had that they have in
development so what you said I agree
with what you said man the format is
dope I really enjoyed the show and um
for anybody hey you know you just
probably that's a Xbox hater Pony or
whatever else
because Xbox told you what was going to
be there they told you the show was
going to be 45 minutes they told you
that
and they told you the game is going to
be there so I just don't know how how
like someone could go through waking up
and the first thing they want to do is
go on Twitter and complain every day
man find out super chat from Jay Robert
uh actually we had one above that oh we
got another one five dollar super trap
from uh car web call call weeb where's
any PS game that isn't Spider-Man or
Wolverine Title these guys you can list
Xbox his entire roadmap but can't list
for Sony games you know what if I had
the gifts I'd say yawn to something you
know I I I I do feel like people be
acting like there's a huge road map for
micro uh for for Sony that's right it is
not there yeah and to be honest with you
after Spider-Man
I don't know anything else well besides
the the like Naughty Dog gang the
multiplayer game yeah we'll see what's
funny is I think I think these
PlayStation people are highly mistaken I
think they're going to start getting
games as a service release after games
as a service yeah absolutely and I I
think they expect like
all these projects that Jim Ryan and
them said that they were working on is
like the games that they even know no
and as much as I hate to say this let a
couple of those games as a service take
off
um and you're going to be seeing real
quick
how much they'll fall back and work on
games and service games because they're
bringing more money and doing that five
dollar Super Chat from Jay uh rumpert
Bert it uh it went from Xbox has no
games to we need release dates people
need to relax
bro you know what I always say even when
it comes to XBox guys you can't please
everybody so is that the point Xbox
should even try to please everybody you
know they you know they have their heart
their hardcore Gamers their fans
announce these games announce release
dates do the best that you can but I
think Xbox knows you can't please
everybody people are always going to
complain about something
the only thing has to just make good
games that's all you don't have to make
games that I like 100 of the time I hope
you make more games than I like and
don't miss a fable
because I'm gonna be very upset if they
mess up my favorite two dollar subscribe
from Spartan go 17. so fake insiders
didn't see that day one drop huh you
know what here's the thing about
insiders insiders only ask questions
about games they care about
uh so when they don't care about certain
games a lot of them don't even ask
and for the most part that I didn't even
hear about that game I heard it was
leaked somewhere yeah but I didn't see
it did you hurt know about that before
God I believe Jeff Grubb leaked it
battle was actually dropping today
that's dope the full game they said no
this is not a demo this is the four game
so yeah and we've been asking them to do
that for years every three things
they're going to shuttle drop this
shuttle dropped I ain't never heard one
person Shadow drop before today all
right those Shadows drop like a demo or
something or like an old ass 360 game or
something and you know what backwards
compatibility is available right now
like
right you can play like Mass Effect one
right now right hold on man that guy
came by the oh seven
yeah I was at E3 when that happened so I
couldn't play basketball 2015. that was
2015. yeah he was at the E3 dope I mean
I recently just watched 20 E3 2015
14 15 I think I was at 2016. so I would
have been home for 15. yeah I was at 16
17 I missed 18 and I was at 19. I think
18 was that best one bro yeah that's the
one where they announced all the studios
right yeah I I was doing a
a reaction with kids smooth okay oh yeah
I remember because
that was before I started you know
streaming and doing like I had a channel
but I was still only have about 300 Subs
back there so I remember listening to
that the kids move was tripling oh my
God
it's crazy I've been doing this for like
almost 10 years yeah yeah
it is what it is we're gonna move on
with that you know that's pretty much
the show guys I appreciate it for coming
through let me put these these uh these
outro time stamps
AJ frills
you see it Xbox dude's been so sorry for
Content they calling this a show of the
year we are not calling this a show of
the Year stop it man it's freaking
January
photos be funny but the thing is is like
it's okay for us to enjoy something that
worked out well because we can all agree
yeah it's not worked out well for us in
a lot of scenarios like inside Xbox
seems to always you know it wasn't that
good like this is the first time that
they did an event outside of that where
it's like it was good so it's okay to
say it's good because
I can assure you Microsoft's gonna mess
up again you're going to have a job
still I can assure you that they're not
Flawless you're right but like you said
this is uh this is good news bro we've
been waiting for something like this
we've been waiting for this we've seen
PlayStation do shows like this Nintendo
we was like when is Xbox going to be
able to do shows like this and I'm happy
that they've able they're able to do
shows like this now meaning they have
more content coming that's all it is Jay
let us Rock bro let us Rocky POS all
right so what what what's going down the
pipeline for you man what do you want to
tell uh the round uh nothing much man
listen guys if you want to hear us hear
a bot
um stream the show I stream the show
earlier on my channel let me um let me
put it in the chat spam it yeah he
always tell me spammy Derek spammy
um yeah so you know um check out the
damn hold on check out
um where the hell is my I'm sorry
what was I saying
[Laughter]
uh what am I looking for I haven't
checked out my channel guys I might have
put the link in the description I mean
in the comment section yeah it was it
was a lot of fun man um so check it out
I'm trying to find I was trying to do my
link on here but I'm doing I'm not doing
it right but go ahead I'm sorry at it
yeah and um
you guys can catch me on Twitter at Lord
addict IOP
um keep in mind me and King are
starting to do R and R with the Lords we
made its own YouTube channel I am
spamming it in the chat because I know
how to do that yeah
um
go to that man subscribe to it you know
uh
definitely support us over there me and
King are trying our own little thing uh
currently it's just cut up stuff from
previous stuff uh but go to that YouTube
link subscribe to it you know if you
don't want to watch everything that we
do on r r with the Lords because I know
sometimes there'll be certain things
that you guys don't want us to talk
about uh you know you're like I haven't
seen Last of Us I don't want to go back
and watch an hour hour and a half
podcasts to catch these certain
individual parts of the videos so we cut
them we cut them up
and we made them their own videos yeah
they're on that they're on that channel
so right now we got episode one and two
uh up currently
on the on that channel of Last of Us uh
we got when we went and watched Megan we
have a review from Megan we have a
review for a sick movie uh it's
literally called sick I'm not saying
it's sick it's called sick and we have a
review for Superman Battle of the super
Suns So currently that's what we have
now my my plan
is to
catch King up on something like um
Attack on Titan
and start covering that when those new
shows come out uh this is how you spam
dirt just saying
that's how you spam the cats uh go go to
dirt go to dirt Channel sub to him now
yeah
sucker
and I appreciate it for coming through
we're going to head this out man I'll
talk to you guys later